From the rainforests of South America to the classrooms of our inner cities,...
...from the purple mountain's majesty...
...to the fruity plain with amber waves of whatever,...
...we could fight to make the world a better place...
...if we only knew why. Think about it.
What do animals do except poop on your lawn...
...and make you feel guilty about how delicious they are?
Why should children be burdened by the tyranny of reading?
Words are hard!
The arts,...
...they don't need your support.
What artists do need is soap.
Seriously, the next time you meet an artist, smell him.
I swear they rub their armpits with onions.
People are always saying, "Get involved."
Well, to them I say, "Sure."
"I'll take a stand."
"For as long as it takes me to find a comfy chair."
That feels good.